let's talk about trust we all know Trust
is fundamental but when it comes to
trusting people something profound is
happening please raise your hand if you
have ever been a host or a guest on a
B&B
wow that's a lot of you who owns Bitcoin
still a lot of you okay and please raise
your hand if you've ever used tinder to
help you find a mate this one's really
hard to count because you're kind of
going like this so these are all
examples of how technology is creating
new mechanisms that are enabling us to
trust unknown people companies and ideas
and yet at the same time trust in
institutions banks governments and even
churches is collapsing so what's
happening here and who do you trust
let's start in France with a platform
with a company where I should say with a
rather funny sounding name blah blah ha
it's a platform that matches drivers and
passengers who want to share long
distance journeys together
the average write taken is 320
kilometers so it's a good idea to choose
your fellow travelers wisely social
profiles and reviews help people make a
choice you can see if someone's a smoker
you can see what kind of music they like
you can see if they're going to bring
their dog along for the ride but it
turns out that the key social identifier
is how much you're going to talk in the
car
blah not a lot flag why are you on a
nice bit of chitchat and blah blah blah
you're not going to stop talking the
entire way from London to Paris
it's remarkable right that this idea
works at all because it's counts the
lesson most of us were taught as a child
never get in a car with a stranger and
yet
blaah blaah car transports more than
four million people every single month
to put that in context that's more
passengers than the Euro cell or JetBlue
airlines carry blahblah car is a
beautiful illustration of how technology
is enabling millions of people across
the world to take a trust leap a trust
leap happens when we take the risk to do
something new or different to the way
that we've always done it let's try to
visualize this together okay I want you
to close your eyes it is a man staring
at me with his eyes wide open I'm on
this big red circle I can see okay so
close your eyes I do it with you and I
want you to imagine there exists a gap
between you and something unknown then
unknown can be someone you've just met
it can be a place you've never been to
it can be something you've never tried
before you got it okay
you can open your eyes now for you to
leap from a place of certainty to take a
chance on that someone or something
unknown you need a force to pull you
over the gap and that remarkable force
is trust Trust is an elusive concept and
yet we depend on it for our lives to
function
I trust my children when they say are
they going to turn the lights out at
night I trusted the pilot who flew me
here to keep me safe it's a word we use
a lot without always thinking about what
it really means and how it works in
different context of our lives there are
in fact hundreds of definitions of trust
and most can be reduced to some kind of
risk assessment of how likely is that
things will go right but I don't like
this definition of trust because it
makes trust sound rational and
predictable and it doesn't really get to
the human essence of what it enables us
to do and how it empowers us to connect
with other people so I define trust a
little differently i define trust as a
confident relationship to the unknown
now when you view trust through this
lens it starts to explain why it has
unique capacity to enable us to cope
with uncertainty to place our faith in
strangers to keep moving forward human
beings are remarkable at taking trust
leaps do you remember the first time you
put your credit card details into a
website that's a trust me I distinctly
remember telling my dad that I wanted to
buy a navy-blue secondhand Peugeot on
eBay and he rightfully pointed out that
the sellers name was invisible wizard
and that this probably was not such a
good idea
so my work my research focuses on how
technology is transforming the social
glue of society trust between people and
it's a fascinating area to study because
there's still so much we do not know for
instance do men and women trust
differently in digital environments does
the way we build trust
face-to-face translates online does
trust transfer so if you trust finding a
mate on tinder are you more likely to
trust finding a ride on bla bla car but
from studying hundreds of networks and
marketplaces there is a common pattern
that people follow and I call it
climbing the trust stack let me use
blah-blah car as an example to bring it
to life on the first level you have to
trust the idea so you have to trust the
idea of ride-sharing is safe and worth
trying the second level is about having
confidence in the platform that bla bla
car will help you if something goes
wrong
and the third level is about using
little bits of information to decide
whether the other person is trustworthy
now the first time we climb the trust
stack it feels weird even risky but we
get to a point where these ideas seem
totally normal
our behaviors transform often relatively
quickly
in other words truss enables change and
innovation so an idea that intrigued me
and I'd like you to consider is whether
we can better understand major ways of
disruption and change in individuals and
society through the lens of trust well
it turns out that Trust has only evolved
in three significant chapters throughout
the course of human history local
institutional and what we're now
entering distributed so for a long time
trust until the mid-1800s trust was
built around tight-knit relationships so
say I lived in a village with the first
five rows of this audience and we all
knew one another and say I wanted to
borrow money the man who had his eyes
wide open he might lend it to me and if
I didn't pay him back you'd all know I
was dodgy I would get a bad reputation
and you would refuse to do business me
in the future
Trust was mostly local and
accountability base in the mid 19th
century Society went through a
tremendous amount of change people moved
to fast-growing cities such as London in
San Francisco and a local banker here
was replaced by large corporations that
didn't know us as individuals we started
to place our trust into black box
systems of authority things like legal
contracts and regulation and insurance
and less trust directly in other people
trusts became institutional and
permission base it's widely talked about
how trust in institutions and many
corporate brands has been steadily
declining and continues to do so I am
constantly stunned by major breaches of
trust the news corp phone hacking the
Volkswagen emissions scandal the
widespread abuse in the Catholic Church
the fact that only one measly banker
went to jail of the great financial
crisis or more recently the Panama
papers that revealed how the rich can
exploit offshore tax regimes and the
thing that really surprises me is that
why the leaders find it so hard to
apologize I mean sincerely apologize
when our trust is broken it would be
easy to conclude that institutional
trust isn't working because we are fed
up with the sheer audacity of dishonest
elites but what's happening now runs
deeper than the rampant questioning of
the size and structure of institutions
we're starting to realize the
institutional trust wasn't designed for
the digital age conventions of how Trust
is built managed lost and repaired in
brands leaders and entire systems is
being turned upside down now this is
exciting but it's frightening because it
forces many of us to have to rethink how
Trust is built and destroyed with our
customers with our employees even our
loved ones the other day I was talking
to the CEO of a leading international
hotel brand and is often the case we got
onto the topic of Airbnb and he admitted
to me that he was perplexed by their
success he was perplexed at how a
company that depends on the willingness
of strangers to trust one another could
work so well across a hundred and
ninety-one countries so I said to him
that I had a confession to make and he
looked at me a bit strangely and I said
and I'm sure many of you do this as well
I I don't always bother to hang my
towels up when I finished in the hotel
but I would never do this as a guest on
Airbnb and the reason why I would never
do this
the guesses they're on Airbnb is because
yes know that they'll be rated by hosts
and that those reigning are likely to
impact their inability to transact in
the future it's a simple illustration of
how online trust will change our
behaviour in the real world make us more
accountable in ways we cannot yet even
imagine I am NOT saying we do not need
hotels or traditional forms of authority
but what we cannot deny is that the way
trust flows through society is changing
and it's creating this big shift away
from the 20th century that was defined
by institutional trust towards the 21st
century that will be fueled by
distributed trust trust is no longer
top-down it's being unbundled and
inverted it's no longer a Paik and
linear a new recipe for trust is
emerging that once again is distributed
amongst people and is accountability
based and this shift is only going to
accelerate with the emergence of the
blockchain the innovative ledger
technology underpinning Bitcoin now
let's be honest getting our heads around
the way blockchain works is mind-blowing
and one of the reasons why is it
involves processing some pretty
complicated concepts with terrible names
I mean cryptographic algorithms and hash
functions and people called miners you
verify transactions all that was created
by this mysterious person called or
persons called Satoshi Nakamoto now that
is a massive trust leap that hasn't
happened yet
but let's try and imagine is so The
Economist's eloquently described the
blockchain as the great chain of being
sure about things the easiest way I can
describe it is imagine the blocks as
spreadsheets and they are filled with
assets so that could be a property title
it could be a stock train it could be a
creative assets such as the rights of
the song every time something moves from
one place on the register to somewhere
else that asset transfer is time-stamped
and publicly recorded on the blockchain
it's that simple right
so the real vacations of the blockchain
is that it removes the need for any kind
of third party such as a lawyer or a
trusted intermediary or maybe not a
government in tahrir degree to
facilitate the exchange so if we go back
to the truss stack you still have to
trust the idea you have to trust the
platform but you don't have to trust the
other person in the traditional sense
the implications are huge in the same
way the internet will open the doors to
an age of information available to
everyone the blockchain will
revolutionize trust on a global scale
now I've waited to the end intentionally
to mention uber because I recognize that
it is a contentious and widely overused
example but in the context of a new era
of trust is a great case study now we
will see cases of abuse of distributed
trust we've already seen this and it can
go horribly wrong I am NOT surprised
that we are seeing protests from taxi
associations all around the world trying
to get governments to ban uber based on
claims that it is unsafe I happened to
be in London the day that these protests
took place and I happen to notice a
tweet from Matt Hancock who is the
British Minister for business and he
wrote does anyone have details of this
uber app everyone is talking about
because I hadn't heard of it until today
now the taxi associations they
legitimize the first layer of the trust
that they legitimize the idea that they
were trying to eliminate and signups
increased by eight hundred and fifty
percent in twenty four hours now this is
a really strong illustration of how a
trust ship once a truss shift has
happened around a behavior or an entire
sector you cannot reverse the story
every day five million people will take
a trust leap and ride with uber in China
on Diddy the ride-sharing platform 11
million rise taken every day that's a
hundred and twenty seven rides per
second showing that this is a cross
cultural phenomenon and the fascinating
thing is that both drivers and
passengers report that by seeing a name
and seeing someone's photo and their
rating makes them feel safer and as you
may have experienced even behave a
little more nicely in the taxi cab uber
and Diddy are early but powerful
examples of how technology is creating
trust between people in ways and on a
scale never possible before today many
of us are comfortable getting into cars
driven by strangers we meet up with
someone we swipe right to be matched
with we share our homes with people we
do not know this is just the beginning
because the real disruption happening
isn't technological it's the trust shift
it creates and for my part I want to
help people understand this new era of
trust so that we can get it right and we
can embrace the opportunities to
redesign systems that are more
transparent inclusive and accountable
thank you very much